this is on leave tomorrow spread the
word
if you jump out of the aeroplane you
cannot clamber back through the cockpit
hatch at times it was hard to pick out
fact from fiction life style is safer
inside the European Union that in
splendid isolation outside it we will
restore power to the people of this
country
I'm an English literature student I know
waffling when I see it that is project
who
the result set britain on a road to a
crisis we must now prepare for a
negotiation with the european union
brexit present the Prime Minister's deal
was rejected before it even reached the
house its delay puts Britain in
uncharted territory a nation split left
wondering what will happen next
[Music]
with British politics in free fall and
brexit in turmoil I've decided to go on
a road trip around the UK and Ireland
you know it's been two and a half years
since Britain voted to leave the EU and
since then brexit has become such a way
of life even down to the way that we
talk you either in you're out you voted
leave or remain you're a romona a brexit
here the backstop customs unions
transition periods Britain became split
and if you think that the passage of
time has healed that you'd be very wrong
Downing Street says Theresa May will
bring her brexit deal back before the
House of Commons this is one of the
biggest wholesale markets in Europe
[Music]
it surprised fresh produce to
restaurants at hotels here Europe and
around the world the key thing about
this place because everything has to be
fresh if Britain crashes out of the EU
without a deal the supply could be held
at the port's by the time it gets here
it could be worthless
our biggest problem will be paperwork if
things get delayed our shipping gets
delayed and we're trading with no no no
flowers so you know we need free
movements and it will affect us what's
at stake for you if we don't get this
right now everything my family my house
everything my staff
yeah we've been trading for 33 years and
I did vote to leave do you regret that I
definitely have second thoughts now but
but when you voted leader do not think
well this is gonna affect my family I
didn't really think about it like that
I didn't really think about the business
side of it
tres may steal seems to be poisoned for
every side so despite the fact I think
she has genuinely tried to you know find
a dividing line and try and make
everybody happy
unfortunately for her I think she's made
everybody angry but think she should be
able to get on with the job in my minds
Morrissey number 10 Jacob Riis moggy
number 11 and Nigel Faraj at the Foreign
Office how about this strong economy is
everything and it is a fact that our
economy will be weaker if we leave and
stronger if we stay what that was David
Cameron's last public speeches Prime
Minister here at Birmingham University
the day before the referendum
I'm heading to meet a businessman just
outside of Birmingham who believes David
Cameron's warnings were well-founded
Greg MacDonald's company makes plastic
parts for the automotive industry he
trades a lot with Europe his views about
brexit didn't always match the views of
his workers
I wrote to our employees and I said to
them that the effects of a voting foot
brexit I the effects of a brexit would
be detrimental to our business and I
told him therefore that it would not be
good for jobs was your advice he did
absolutely know most workers not all
ended according to me
how did you vote in the referendum they
were to come out you brought it to me
yes and why did you vote early
it was mainly by the government
Wesley Boris Johnson saying we were
going to be better off with the NHS he
does and fifty billion player never
happened I understand your boss wrote a
letter before the referendum saying I
would like it as thought remain yes
why did you you're perfectly entitled to
why did you go against an advice I never
took it advice you know
pinch of salt river are you worried
about your turn yet course I am because
my mortgage you know I may find my bills
a Tom you know I mean so that's that's
why it's all about and Greta mom and
Greg doing a really good job of trying
to apples all there so you mentioned
brexit there have you thought about it
the Stein
yeah and I know Craig wrote a letter to
the stuff yeah yeah yeah they find like
they were they we didn't box they call
those are jobs my instinct is to not
have all my investment in briggsie land
and to move over to central Eastern
Europe as a conduit for doing business
in Europe the waters are going to be
choppy and I don't think business is
encouraged to make investment in choppy
waters they would rather go and invest
in other countries for example in the
euro zone I said to them well you voted
that way so if it doesn't go well yeah
who've you got to blame breaking news
this hour a vote of no-confidence has
now been triggered on Teresa Mays
leadership I've come 170 miles west to
Wales and I've come here because it has
something that's critical to trade the
economy and the supply of goods
a port a No Deal brexit could see
increased checks at ports like Holyhead
80% of Irish lorries heading for the
continent passed through Welsh ports
checks here could be bad for business
poly head is such a crucial trading port
half a million lorries passed through
here each year it's massive I'm really
interested to find out what people think
about brexit and how they think their
lives might be changed if we leave
without a decent deal Anglesey was
pretty much split down the middle in the
referendum vote but the leaves weren't
it but only just talk in the truck stop
here is about the future I don't think
it's gonna affect the lives of a lot
ezel the ones in the trade but I just
wanted to go look at there it's taken a
long long time isn't it
you know I think it's just a big mass to
be honest with you so we're just you
know we're all waiting aren't we you
know for the big day March said it's
just scare mongering mayor's you know
they're afraid of the unknown but we
will create Britain before we enter the
util at week so why can't he be again
why why do we have to pay all that money
into Europe and not get what we paid
back
she wasn't a brexit she was a remain so
how can you have a remainer striking a
deal - deal so good to come out doesn't
work you must have that movement of
trips I couldn't have the same thing
for a length of time also would the
Irish companies then decide to move on
to somewhere else and bypass Britain to
get in that's another question the fear
is that that that happens and that Holly
head goes from being one of the busiest
ports in the UK to actually being
bypassed that would not be good would it
certainly not for here not for the port
of Holyhead not for our business and not
Frankie at all in the next leg of my
journey I'm heading to Island an EU
nation that stands to lose a lot in a
bad break City if the British people
don't reach an agreement they will be
much worse off for the next 10 years
and we fly into a storm and Shetland
an island split by grexit we're
surrounded by farmers from Lourdes
different nations and taken more fish
out of the water than we're allowed to
she couldn't be more linked to being you
but a very much like to be and needs to
stay like good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen to the captain and Sean Hanley
termed speaking now I'm heading to
island via the ferry from Holly head
this is a major trade route from Island
to the EU brexit has the potential to
really disrupt the flow here keywords
adventurer many thanks so that's as
clear the evening crossings very popular
for the freight pieces usually about two
Emirates Lisa preys on those crossings
and what would the route be if you
bypassed the UK altogether and you have
to go from Island straight to the
continent much longer it would take a
lot longer it would take probably about
24 hours 18 to 24 hours
it's very weather dependent and the
Southwest approaches the weather's
really really bad and in the winter you
could be holed up for a couple of days
trying to get around that route it's
tier two nine zero please Med ships the
whales so a route bypassing the UK and
heading direct to the continent would be
three times as long it's here in the
Irish Sea with the complexities of
brexit become clear at the moment trade
passes from the UK to Ireland and back
unhindered for after two and a half
years of negotiation no one can agree
what this crossing and others might look
like after we leave the EU
and that is a big problem to prime
ministers in Brussels for more brexit
talks after winning a votes of
confidence that victory means she can't
be challenged again through a year
labour says missus maybe it's early
evening in Dublin the lorries waste no
time disembarking it looks easy no
customs checks if we leave without a
deal it could be a different story
especially as the UK government is
warning businesses to prepare for the
worst thank you for joining me tonight
Verona Murphy doesn't mince her yards
she's a holier she used to drive lorries
and now she represents the industry I'm
a holier in Ireland for 27 years and I
worked mainly from Ireland to Italy
carrying a beef product and absolutely
fruit and veg often quite often back to
the UK and then from the UK to Ireland
you can see how busy it is here we have
four ships leaving here for Heysham
Liverpool and two to Holly heads it
takes a huge amount of traffic but it
also brings the product for the UK
supermarket chains here in Ireland of
which there are money and look at it is
a link that cannot be broken if it if we
have breakfast we're gonna have huge
disruption we're going to have huge loss
in business but it will recover but I do
not see that it will recover for the
British people who will find it very
very difficult if the British people
don't reach an agreement they will be
much worse off for the next ten years
than they even anticipate I don't think
they really understand hot breaks it
means it means queues in airports queues
at ports you can no longer just decide
you want to go somewhere because you're
not only you citizen you may require a
visa everybody has to be thought your
industry on this side of the Irish
Channel would say that because you're
faced with nodes losses and where you
gonna send your lorries but you must
remember we're a country that produces
over 25 million people's food I think
the problem in the UK is that you have
the MPs playing politics and not giving
real thought to how the people of
Britain will be affected welcome back to
morning Ireland it's 13 minutes past
8:00 well yesterday the British prime
minister Theresa May went to Brussels to
try to secure concessions I've come to
the heart of one of the big brexit
headings the Irish border to prevent
checks here the UK government came up
with a way of avoiding it it's called
the backstop it would mean Northern
Ireland would stay aligned to some rules
of the EU single market if other
solutions can't be found by the end of
the transition period in December 2020
many here want a backstop I'm off to
meet a businessman who's really worried
about the prospect of a hard border here
so much so that he's taken some quite
drastic action to protect his business
in the event of that happening here he
is here
dawn how are you this is dawn redden and
his business sits right on the border
and when I say right on the border I
mean it
I bought a yard adjacent to our yard and
on a goal which is actually in Northern
Ireland in the UK and we've set up a
completely separate company and Northern
Ireland who and kiss brexit what
happened so so this this way is that's
not violent you go out there you're in
the EU Republic of Ireland and this way
that there is the UK arguably into the
UK so you've got two gates to this yard
yes
just in case just show me around let's
have a chance so we're we're good I'll
be able to show you the the border
crossing the border runs right through
the middle of Don's land and he's taking
advantage of that oh so you but you've
actually built width on the job a new
road
so we're crossing the border now Dawn
has two of everything now the bridge is
a border so one entrance at the side
into the Republic of Ireland yes
this entrance at the back yet into the
UK yeah
gives you the best of both worlds Marcus
and what will it mean you can do
well it means we can create in Europe as
we are and it means that if there is a
hard border or a hard brexit that we are
already in the UK so when are we in the
UK you're about to cross a third of it
we're to build the bridge as well
Republic of Ireland Northern Ireland UK
I called it the bridge over troubled
water do you have faith in the UK
government to find a way through so that
you don't need to do this
hopefully hopefully hopefully I'm hoping
on the eleventh eye or someone's gonna
chop me and this has been the plan all
along I'll come up with a real good deed
and though everyone won't they having oh
well how likely do you think that is I'm
an optimist hopefully you have to be an
optimist don't you hope you have to be
an activist I'm hoping like it's not
over yet
Theresa May believes it's still possible
to get the assurances from Europe that
MPs need Dom's not alone with his
concerns for those who were brought up
during the troubles in Northern Ireland
a return to custom checks on the border
would be a huge step back this is what
stopping everything no this back stop
I'm meeting Alain Doherty in Derry
she's been campaigning to avoid a hard
border what actually are the details of
a hard breaks it could someone write
down and a list what exactly will happen
my concern is that we would have borders
again
that's you know it would affect our
everyday life and the way we work here
and the way we live here I think
particularly borders are very disruptive
they disrupt the social fabric of life
they will disrupt the economy and the
trade as well I think they're very
divisive also and they divide people the
debate families and the also divide land
it's quite quite unique and what we've
experienced in the past and it's this
it's quite fragile also one of trees
amazed top team is born in the country
will face serious trouble if enemies for
Shetland is the most northerly tip of
the UK it's closer to Oslo than London
the fishermen here are watching
Westminster as closely as they watch the
weather brexit means getting out of the
Common Fisheries Policy which would give
the UK control of how much fish can be
caught and who can access its waters
I've come to scalloway the ancient
capital of this island but not
everyone's against brexit here this is
already fraternity yeah Robert
Williamson runs a shellfish processes
and this is coming in to the factory
floor where we he's just had a quarter
of a million pounds from the EU to build
new premises what are your big concerns
out of all of this well our biggest
concern is just the uncertainty of what
it's actually going to happen whether
it's a head brexit or a deal but if
things is made more difficult that
impacts our business what would what
would the next day trading looked like
if we crashed out without a deal
for you it's very difficult to say
because at this moment we're two months
away from possibly crashing out and we
still don't know what the effect is
going to be and that's that's very
worrying so all of this you know this
was made made happen through he you
money you've got in you any new
workforce you couldn't be more linked to
the EU we're very much like the
and that needs to stay like that does
this start to keep you awake at night
no not got to that not got to that stage
yet I there's not much we can do about
it at the moment that's also the the
worryin thing we just need to wait and
see what happens with the politicians do
you have faith in them mmm not really if
you could speak to the Prime Minister
what would you say to her that we need
to have a deal that doesn't make things
any more difficult than what they are at
the moment does she get it you think do
you think she understands her I actually
think she does there to be honest
[Music]
as light falls over Shetland I'm off to
meet a fisherman who says brexit offers
fairer future for him and his family
hi nice to meet ya
Gary Smith has been a fisherman for more
than 30 years I voted for blacks it's
basically to hopefully secure a better
future for our fashion industry here in
gentlemen were surrounded by farmers
from Lourdes different nations that
catch and far more fish and taken more
fish out the waters than we're allowed
to the Common Fisheries Policy tells us
that if we catch too much of a certain
species who got throw them back in the
sea day it's wrong that's that's why I
voted for Braxton do you have faith in
the prime minister in the government to
pull this deal off the kind of deal that
you thought you know not at all no I
think she's too hung up on Irish but
she's too hung up on today it deals and
immigration and stuff professions
nothing
the government now Ward's at preparation
for a No Deal brexit must get under way
they say it's a precaution the people I
met remains split I don't really know
how we're going to get out of this
muddle but some way that some way will
find a way and and I suspect it's not
going to be we're not going to be in a
better position afterwards than we were
before the vote some formatting that
that that secured her future it's a huge
mess it's chaotic and I think
unfortunately politics in the UK is
chaotic as the worry ometer starting to
run think businesses need to the you
know it is serious now the new year will
bring a new vote and a new chapter for
Britain for good or ill will be opened
you